[Music]
who came up with the idea of the eu and
why
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a so how then did the european coal and
steel community become the eu
[Music]
conrad
[Music]
what is the common market for goods and
services and why was this such a big
step forward
vice versa
when did ireland and all the current
members join and when exactly did the
eec become the eu
football league
is
[Music]
so why was it so important for ireland
to become a member
and why did we fight so hard to gain
membership
behavior in the media
[Music]
and
so it's been really good for the irish
export industry and that is good news
for our economy however how has eu
membership helped ordinary irish people
continue the bumper she is smooth like
being segregated
so if i want to travel to other member
states can i use the same mirror that i
use here in ireland to buy things
to smooth in the chair of the s
[Music]
how does eu help with irish consumers
when they want to buy goods
i believe in equal rights for all
what has the eu done to improve the
rights of irish women
essentially
and what about day-to-day life has being
in the eu made it easier to live in
ireland
herbert
[Music]
joining the eu has done a lot for
ireland in the past
but ireland faces future challenges due
to brexit and the covert 19 pandemic
how will the eu help
the effort all work pending covered in
the diego
to my community what will the eu do to
help irish farmers
[Music]
say
foreign
[Music]
i care very much about nature
and the effects of global warming on the
world and ireland
what is the eu
doing about the climate emergency
[Music]
growing up all i've ever known is a
digital world but a lot of people older
than me are still getting used to a tech
world
what is the eu doing to speed up that
change
the gallagher digital new week falls
how does the eu impact on the rest of
the world
scooch froze the name to say gold sharon
john taurus more down modula
hurts the heroes
[Music]
so if eu member states make important
decisions about certain things
how do they do it and where do they do
it from
the tree instituted
a commission
enthusiast
the european commission based in
brussels is responsible for the
day-to-day running of the eu it is
responsible for proposing policies and
new laws
and this is decided upon
by a college of 27 commissioners one
from each member state
the european parliament approves the
president of the commission the current
president of commission is ursula van
der line who is from germany
and the term of office is five years
both for the president and for the
college of commissioners
[Music]
what responsibilities do individual
commissioners have and whose views do
they represent
the commissioner
in my case that's everything to do with
the financial system the stock market
and financial stability but i'm also
dealing with new things like digital
innovation in the financial area and
very importantly how we could get money
invested in the green recovery and i
think that's a hugely important issue
i'm from ireland but at the college i
represent all of europe not just ireland
how does a commissioner decide which two
laws to propose
so essentially the college of
commissioners draft legislation or
indeed change existing legislation but
we don't do it on our own we listen to
stakeholders those who have an interest
in that policy area and sometimes we ask
people to give us their views of what's
coming up
how can ordinary people have a say into
proposed or existing
you can log on and give your views on
specific issues that are open for public
consultations and a very important
public consultation underway at the
moment is the conference on the future
of europe we really would welcome young
people's views as to how the european
union should look in the future
and how does a policy proposal become an
actual eu lab
once a policy proposal is approved by
the 27 commissioners it then moves
forward to the council of the european
union
and to the european parliament and both
those european institutions then decide
whether it will become a law or not
add a real fish on the balls touch eggs
olivia in their horion into zoro prey
i've spent the harry auburn lloyd a
brady canal tiger barfish with her guest
[Music]
how often are members of the european
parliament elected is it lock bottle and
anti-ship
the allocation of mep seats is based
purely on population size um and the
more the country grows the more
possibility they'll be able to add meps
in ireland we have 13 in total
once a month we vote in what we call
plenary so voting sessions and they are
done in strasbourg in france the other
three weeks of the month we have
meetings in brussels in belgium
does the european parliament and the
council of the european union always
agree on new laws
when the council and the parliament
don't agree on legislation which is
actually quite a lot we have to meet up
and agree a compromise before a new law
is enacted negotiations begin each side
outlining the important issues for them
and it's about concentrating on the
issues that unite us rather than divide
us
once a law is adopted it is the role of
the european commission to ensure that
it is properly applied in all member
states
what role does our t-shirt have in
european union
pantry
rectal and chakra molly realtor in the
blind
okay i'm beginning to understand how it
all works but are there any more eu
institutions
institute
[Music]
all of the eu institutions exist to
ensure that the european union operates
in an open democratic and transparent
way and that citizens interests and
rights are protected
[Music]
what about working for the eu are there
many opportunities for young people
dr jester harter [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm based in brussels my job involves
all sorts of communication
my speciality is social media so i get
to research what works and what doesn't
work on social media
so i started as a trainee in the
communication unit traineeships are
important because you
need people to explain things to you
it's also important for making friends
and
meeting people who are at the same stage
of life that you're at at the same stage
of career that you're at
le tilla all the charles
epso punk europa punky you full slash
job opportunities full slash
traineeships
aside from traineeships what other
long-term career prospects does the
european union offer
[Music]
fasting institutions
[Music]
i'm a communications manager at
eurofound located in dublin and our role
is to provide knowledge and information
to eu policymakers and national
governments and social partners to help
them shape better policies for citizens
whether it's gender issues industrial
relations employment and bigger issues
like climate change
i work in a multicultural environment i
work with people from lots of different
countries and it's great to be part of
the european project but at the same
time as an irish person i get to live in
ireland diversity is also one of the
reasons that i love working in the
european commission you get people from
all over europe but also all over the
world and
you're never short of an interesting
conversation
so if i had any advice for young people
i'd say brush up on your languages if
you can arm yourself with french with
spanish or another language i think so
many more doors will be opened to you
erin get lot of vienna though
um
[Music]
as a young person who wants to find out
even more about the eu and get involved
what can i do
tanyard valley is
i'm proud to be a member of the eu
family
it's a very big family
there are
450 million of us in 27 member countries
and as an eu citizen i can travel freely
to any of these countries
i can shop without any extra tariff or
cost
for goods and services from any one of
the member states
and thanks to eu laws both me
and me have the right to equal pay for
equal work
[Music]
and every eu citizen can work freely
in any one of the 27 member countries
facebook
[Music]
you